nous allons voir le sujet tout de suite
dans trois secondes
15 août sept heures du matin place de la
concorde les premières colonnes
allemandes pénètre dans paris non
rassurez vous en dehors des touristes
les allemands n'occupe pas de nouveau la
capitale
il s'agit comme souvent cette période du
tournage d'un film
le sang des autres avec en vedette jodie
foster qui fut notamment l'interprète
principal de bugsy malone et taxi driver
quel personnage vous dans ses films une
fille qui s'appelle hélène bertrand une
jeune aussi mieres l'emprunteuse et
coûteuses dans un accord qui tombe
amoureux d'un soldat en faillite
ardemment pendant l'occupation
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse dans ce
rôle et surtout de travailler avec
chabrol et de faire un d'adapter un
roman décès de simone de beauvoir la csn
physique arrêteront moteur la rolls peu
plus haut le club
a lens 1re et en effet pour la première
fois simone de beauvoir a accepté qu'une
de ses oeuvres soient portées au grand
écran
une coproduction américano canadienne
avec la participation dans ten de
réalisateurs et français claude chabrol
et c'est un livre très étrange parce
qu'on est normalement de lennox entre
les pages
alors j'ose le travail du scénariste a
été de prendre ce que tu entres les
tâches de dures sortie on retrouvera
quand même ce qu'il ya dans les pages un
peu et mangue
il ya et ce qui viole les pages chine ce
qui vient autres nicole figurants
bâtiment et l'obélisque elle même tous
ont revêtu leurs costumes d'époque
d'importants moyens ont été mis à la
disposition de claude chabrol et bien
que l'équipe soit française l'ambiance
du tournage ne dépayse pas trop
l'actrice américaine
comment s'est passé le tournage avec
légumes française par rapport à un
tournage avec une équipe américaine
c'est toujours pareil toujours les mêmes
jean lé même blouson c'est comme si
on avait sa famille partout qui pose
l'ambiance est la même oui petite fille
sérieux ici fait dire aux états unis
rémois sérieux en blague j'ai trop fait
vous l'avez remarqué
jodie foster parle parfaitement le
français quand elle a eu dix ans ses
parents l'ont placé dans un lycée
français aux états unis et jugeait que
c'était une parfaite éducation pour une
jeune fille